would you tell me what happened with
Superman because I cannot tell you that
I was anticipating two films I'm a huge
super comic-book fan and stuff and I've
had Jim Cameron on and he was gonna do
spider-man which I was excited about and
you were gonna do Superman which I was
excited about with Nicolas Cage is super
good I said this is gonna be great yes
and what went wrong well you know these
students become like these big
corporations and you just havin to like
design characters for happy meals before
you design up for the film you know and
but you have such credibility they know
that the good Batman was the first
Batman were you they don't know nobody
still the second one they thought was
like the I upset McDonald's because they
thought it was too dark black stuff
coming out of the Penguins mouth was too
close to the ingredients of their food
or something it was too vile yeah
penguin is vile you know it's like you
want to treat this stuff seriously not
like an Ice Capades show or something
you know and right so what the reason we
like Batman and this is what I always
said
was that it was treated seriously like a
real story it was a real guy was a real
guy he had real problems you had
dilemmas he even had a problem with that
he was Batman right exactly and that was
what was great about the comic book and
you tapped into that well that's why I
didn't want to put Robin into it -
because once you put that into it you
know the whole other yeah what's he
doing hanging around with this on the
rage boy yeah I can't figure this out
Underpants together it wasn't right it's
hard enough to pull up just Batman
exactly yeah so and the point is that I
thought I said gee what a brilliant move
that they got the the darkness of Batman
but they ruined the franchise's anything
well yeah I mean if luckily the first
move I never heard the word franchise
that sort of developed over the last
couple of years you know it just gets
more and more away from making a film
and you know you're just like I said
you're sitting in a room before you've
got characters designed for the film you
know it's like they need it for the
t-shirt they need it for the cup you
know they need it for all that and it's
just like and that doesn't work it's got
to be a great film and then all of that
will come exactly hopefully so
what I heard was Superman they they had
you know they tried to get a whole bunch
of people to do it or whatever wasn't
working out and and like Kevin Smith who
was just here written script and and
then they've got you yeah and I said
once they got you that's an automatic
greenlight page which was very exciting
I felt like for the first time you could
like with Nick you could say like guy
who is Clark Kent and you can see the
change you can see right becoming
something else you had a real good actor
in there Superman character that was the
one character that it was never really
portrayed with any death Yeah right like
and why does Superman have to be the
perfect looking guy anyway he was from
another dude from another planet now I
know yeah it's like well first we're
looking at Batman's they were trying to
like unload like guys that looked like
Arnold Schwarzenegger
strong guys with pointy ears I thought
it was amazing when you cast Michael
King because I think Michael key but it
totally worked
he looks crazy you know and you know and
Nicolas Cage looks like he's from
another planet if you ask me so I
thought he was perfect exactly
so you had him lined up he was committed
yeah yeah absolutely and and and you had
a script or no you know studios you
don't have scripts unfortunately anyway
that's how it works
I have trouble don't you have trouble
reading I hate reading those scripts
I have trouble even reading my own
scripts so you mean to tell me you would
have made Superman without a script
really no kidding but you know it just
was crazy I mean the producers they
didn't I had one meeting where we were
looking at the suit and in the studio
and the producer were going you know we
don't want the like the suit you know
we're afraid of the red and they wanted
to have him look like Michael Jordan
shorts right leg oh no they said to like
this the costume designer night we were
looking at each other like we good
we see him wearing corduroy as Superman
like
I don't even understand women other--
planet even have corner I encrypted then
they said maybe give them boots but you
know like on the site of event like like
with flames on it right right right
make a fart match right that was closer
to the super yes it was